a message of peace which came after a
turbulent year in his annual Christmas
address Germany's President URM garg
asked Germans not to turn their back on
those in need well via de to buy Tonkin
and where we can help bring peace ease
pain and build a better future for
others to confirmation do that with all
of our hearts in a match did an
increasing number of migrants lived to
Germany for their future this year more
than 200,000 refugees applied for asylum
in the country eighty thousand of those
came from Syria billon expects even more
refugees to apply next year garg praised
those who support Berlin's decision to
keep Germany's doors open that's we
admit fool endure this year I have been
truly encouraged by the fact that the
great majority of us do not follow those
who want to seal Germany off from the
rest of the world anavar mot gandi foul
Jesus years regardless of whether it's
fighting Ebola in Africa or helping out
a neighbor at home Germany's president
called on everyone to do what they could
to make the world a better place via
Allah Kony can all do something to keep
the spirit of giving alive without it
the world would be a cold and friendless
place indian villains and we have to get
involved and help our neighbors out when
they need it indy via be bought we need
to provide shelter to be afflicted east
to the persecuted foots people garg also
spoke to those who are worried by the
crises and conflicts around the world
his message was a simple one inspired by
the biblical Christmas story fear not